[Musique]
le verbe doux petit hameau de la région
de Lannion n'avait sans doute jamais
reçu le président de la République la
présence de la station de
télécommunications spatiale lui a valu
en même temps que la célébrité mondiale
cette réparation de l'histoire le
général de Gaulle est en effet venu
inaugurer officiellement la station
bretonne et admirait l'oreille géante
qui capte sous le radôme les ondes venus
des USA via le satellite telsta le
général de Gaulle avait du reste
personnellement rendez-vous avec Telstar
ou du moins par son intermédiaire avec
l'ambassadeur de France aux États-Unis
c'était pour Monsieur Hervé alpha un
rendez-vous matinal à New York il était
5 heures du matin
[Musique]
l'approche du référendum s'est traduite
sur les murs et les panneaux électoraux
par les prises de position des
différentes formations politiques
de son côté le chef de l'État après
avoir rappelé les tâches que la nouvelle
Constitution lui avait permis de mener à
bien a déclaré
comme la preuve est ainsi faite
de la valeur d'une constitution qui veut
que l'État est une tête
comme depuis que je joue ce rôle
personne n'a jamais pensé que le
Président de la République était là pour
autre chose
je crois en toute conscience
que le peuple doit maintenant
par un vote solennel
marqué qu'il veut qu'il en soit ainsi
aujourd'hui demain et plus tard
le tel des monnaies prépare l'ultime
offensif du nouveau franc fixé au 1er
janvier prochain à cette date ce sera en
effet officiellement la cohabitation des
anciens et des nouveaux francs il n'y
aura plus qu'un seul franc qui vaudra
simplement 100 centimes de nouvelles
pièces seront alors mises en circulation
50 centimes 20 centimes on retrouvera
aussi les deux souhaits le sous d'autres
fois un sou sera de nouveau un sous pour
longtemps espérant le
[Musique]
de la Colombie-Britannique à San
Francisco les habitants de la côte ouest
des États-Unis ont une fois de plus
constaté que l’océan Pacifique n'est pas
aussi débonnaire que son nom l'indique
des tornades venus de la mer ont déversé
sur le pays des tonnes d'eau durant 3
jours on a vu des escaliers transformés
en cascade et des autos en bateau 40
morts noyade ou accidents divers dual
inondation
un homme pourtant a gardé un moral à
toute épreuve ce gardien de stade a
profité de la pluie pour immêler des
produits chimiques et effectuer ainsi
son nettoyage
[Musique]
malgré le climat d'insécurité qui règne
au confins du Tibet en raison des
attaques chinoises certaines œuvres
d'assistance à l'enfance continuent à
apporter au petit garçon et aux petites
filles des plus hautes montagnes du
monde soit et enseignement
[Musique]
le dalaï-lama vient parfois assez faites
enfantines encouragées ceux qui
poursuivent leur mission éducatrice et
pour une salanité d'une telle importance
où le Dieu vivant apparaît en public
fête et danse célèbre l'événement
[Musique]
le commerce des toit et autres
gouttières n'a pas empêché Marcel
Garnier plombier zinguer de son état de
cultiver aussi le commerce des Muses au
contraire peut-être à tel point en tout
cas qu'une envie la saisie devenir
immortelle quad plus naturel nous
l'avons interrogé sur cette audacieuse
tentation que vous avez posé récemment
votre candidature à l'Académie française
au fauteuil de Pierre Benoit exactement
et cette lettre je crois que vous l'avez
écrit en vert en alexandrin alors
écoutez monsieur Garnier et nous serions
très heureux si vous vouliez nous à lire
voilà j'ai fait un rêve oubliez mon
adresse bon couvre et plombier et poète
à la fois je voudrais parmi vous très
bientôt prendre place de venir immortel
en entrant par le toit
alors pour vous servir sur votre
couverture j'efface les trous avec du
vilain ce sera la paiement de ma
candidature et le prix d'un fauteuil
même d'un strapontin enfin bien habillé
de vert bicorne en tête j'entrerai près
de vous dans l'immortalité ayant un
institut ainsi fait la conquête là on
passe soudé au point et l'épée aux côtés
d'ores et déjà la candidature de Marcel
Garnier a été rejetée le Secrétaire
perpétuel a été net il y a eu vice de
forme revenus assez robinets il reste au
plombier poète à méditer sur la sévérité
du protocole
[Musique]
par certains de ses côtés le cinéma
s'apparente à la magie comme elle
possède ses secrets pour faire rêver des
jeux de miroir de lentilles de prisme
permettent aujourd'hui par exemple ses
effets saisissants de multiplication à
l'infini d'un sujet unique
[Musique]
une main et une rose c'est tout un balai
mais le magicien du film peut encore
faire plus donner le cadre du Mont Blanc
à des personnages installés le plus
prosaïquement du monde
dans un champ d'Île-de-France un dessin
une photo suffise à créer l'illusion il
suffit de les placer dans le Simplifilm
un système optique mis au point
parachute Dufour et qui se fixe devant
la caméra pour réaliser ce tour de
passe-passe
et deux personnages sur un sentier
auront l'air de passer sous la porte du
château de Blois
[Musique]
ainsi des géants pourront se profiler
au-dessus des châteaux
de grandes étendues apocalyptiques
croyez-vous en vérité une maquette de
très petite dimension on installera
aussi facilement un personnage sur un
doigt de la main que sur le dos d'une
gargouille
et on pourra faire danser un balai dans
le décor de l'Opéra sur un simple
plateau de studio depuis Méliès la
machine des magiciens du film c'est
notablement réduit
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
jouer à Vienne ce n'est jamais très rose
pour une équipe étrangère et la contre
elle non seulement l'équipe adverse mais
également les 50 000 excités des
tribunes près à n'importe quoi pourvu
que leurs favoris gagne les Rémois
maillot à manches blanches qui étaient
pas très rassurées lorsqu'ils ont entamé
leur match de Coupe d'Europe contre
Australia dans la capitale autrichienne
et il n'avait pas tout à fait tort à
peine 12 minutes de jus premier bu
autrichi
3 minutes plus tard Reims égalise sur
penalty que tire sauvage voilà qui est
fait
et puis les Autrichiens donnent des
frissons aux joueurs français mais rien
ne passe Colona arrête tout
[Applaudissements]
tout sauf l'admirable reprise de voler
de l'évier droit autrichien sur corner
cela semble être le début de la
catastrophe pour Reims dans l'équipe de
surcroît est handicapé par l'expulsion
de son intergo jean Vincent pour
brutalité paraît-il alors que les autres
chiens n'ont jamais cessé de multiplier
les provocations et Austria se fait
ainsi un troisième but
les joueurs français après avoir fourni
le pire redresse la barre et marquent un
second but qui leur permet d'espérer que
tout n'est pas perdu pour le match
retour qui aura lieu à Paris cette fois
[Musique]